one of the hesitancies around vaccines
or basically around any new technology
is the fact that mrna is a new idea
and it's an idea that was shrouded in
some skepticism as you said but it's the
scientific community because it's like
it's a it's a
cool new technology
surprising that it works
what's your intuition
i think one nice way to approach this is
um
try to play devil's advocate and say
both sides one side is why your
intuition says that it's safe for humans
and what arguments can you see
if you could steal man and argument why
it's unsafe for humans
or
not unsafe for humans but
the hesitancy to take an mrna vaccine is
justified
so many people
are afraid because it's new technology
and they feel it hasn't been
tested
i mean in theory what could go wrong
this is the nice thing about
mrna
is that it doesn't last forever
as opposed to dna which doesn't last
forever but it can last a lot longer
and it could even go into your dna right
so mrna has a
shorter lifetime maybe days after it's
injected into your arm then it's gone
so that's a good thing because it's not
going to be around forever
so that would say okay so
it's sticking around for your lifetime
it's not happening but what else could
happen
well
the let's see the protein that's made
could that be an issue
and again proteins
don't last forever they have a finite
longevity in the body
and this one also
lasts perhaps at the best a few weeks
now this is a protein that's made after
the the rna gets into the cell yeah so
the lipid nanoparticles taken up into a
cell and the mrna is translated and you
get protein made and there's also a
question i'm sorry to interrupt where
where in the body so because it's not
well targeted
or
i don't i don't know if it's supposed to
be targeted but it can go throughout the
body that's one right so it's injected
deep into your deltoid muscle right your
shoulder
and
the idea is not to put it in a blood
vessel otherwise it would then for sure
circulate everywhere so
they go deep in a blood vessel and it's
it's locally injected and they did
before this even went into people they
did experiments in mice where they gave
them
a thousand times higher concentrations
than they would ever give to people and
then when you do that it can go
everywhere basically you can find this
these nanoparticles in every tissue of
the mouse
but that's at a thousand-fold higher
concentration right so
i think
at the levels that we're using in people
most of it's staying in the muscle but
sure small small amounts go elsewhere
could there be a lot of harm caused if
it goes elsewhere in like let's say
ridiculously high quantities i'm trying
to understand what is the damage that
could be done
from an rna just floating about
so the rna itself is not going to be a
problem it's the protein that is the
protein encoded in it right this is a
viral rna which
has no sequence in us so there's nothing
that it could do it's the protein that i
would say
you you could ask what is that going to
do
and
the one property we know about
the spike
is that it can cause fusion
of cells
right that's how the virus gets in in
the beginning the spike attaches to the
cell by this h2 receptor and it
causes the virus
and the cell to fuse
and that's how the rna gets out of the
particle but so wait uh i'm a bit
confused so with this mrna vaccine with
the lipids and the rna there's no spike
right
the the mrna codes for the spike oh the
mrna codes so it creates the spike it
creates a spike so that spike could
cause fusion of cells yes except
they modified the spike so it wouldn't
got it they made two amino acid changes
in the spike so it would not fuse so
they understand enough which amino acids
are responsible for the fusion that's
right interesting this is so they could
modify it so now it's not going to cause
fusion so that's not an issue it's
called the prefusion stabilized spike
um
so the spike when it binds ace too
that that top falls off and the spike
and the part of the spike that causes
fusion is now exposed and that doesn't
happen in this mrna vaccine so
those are the things that could have
happened but i think they're
ruled out by
what we've just said but there's no
better test than putting it into people
right right and doing phase one phase
two and phase three in increasing
numbers of people and asking what do we
see do we do we have any concerns and so
now it's been in
many millions of people
and we don't see
most of the effects you see in a vaccine
you see in the first couple of months
things like the myocarditis with some of
the vaccines the clotting issues with
the astrazeneca vaccine guillain-barre
you see those
relatively quickly
um
and we've seen small numbers of those
occur
but um
other things we haven't seen and
you know you you never say never right
right so i mean this is fascinating
right
it's like uh
i i drink
uh i put splenda in my coffee
and uh has
supposedly uh no calories
but it tastes really good
and i this despite what like rumors and
blogs and so on i have not seen good
medical evidence
that is harmful to you
but it's like it tastes too good
so i'm thinking like there's got to be
long-term consequences but it's very
difficult to understand what the
long-term consequences are
uh like that
and there's this kind of
like distant fear or anxiety about it
like this thing tastes too good it's too
good to be true
there's got to be there's no free launch
in this world
this is the kind of feeling that people
have about the long-term effects of the
vaccine
that
you mentioned that there's some
intuition about near-term effects that
you want to uh
uh remove like the diffusion of cells
and all those kinds of things but they
think okay this travels to other cells
in the body it travels to
neurons or that kind of stuff and then
what kind of effect does that have long
term that's yet to be discovered
what do you make i mean for this vaccine
but in general in science about
making statements about long-term
uh negative effects
is that something that weighs heavy on
you is that something we can kind of
escape through just large-scale
experimentation
with human with animals and humans well
if you're really
if you're concerned about long-term then
you have to do a long-term experiment
right
and
maybe you don't see something for 50-60
years so
if someone says to you there are no
long-term effects of the covid vaccines
they can't say that because they haven't
done the long experiment right right
there's always the possibility but you
have to weigh it it's always
there's no free lunch right
there's always a risk benefit
calculation you have to make you can
have the study that goes for 50 years
and and then decide but i guess what
you're doing is you
just like we said um
i forget with which one with polio with
rabies i forget but you're weighing
the side effects yeah
the vaccine versus
the effects of the virus
and like both of them you don't know
long-term effects
but you're building up intuition as you
study which what are the long-term
effects like there there's a huge number
of
people
like
um
that have like i don't want to say
experts because i don't like the word
but people have studied it long enough
to where they build up intuition they
don't know for sure there's basic
science being done in this basic studies
we start to build up an intuition
of
what
might be a problem down the line and
what is not biologically speaking and so
given that map you then considering the
virus
there seems to be a lot of evidence for
covid having
negative effects
on
all aspects of the body not just even
respiratory which is kind of interesting
right so the cognitive stuff that's
terrifying all kinds of systems of
autism yes
and then you look at the same thing with
the vaccine
and there seems to be less of that
but of course you don't know
if it's some kind of dormant thing
that's just going to you won't know it's
you have to
make a judgment and for a lot of people
they can't right because they don't have
the tools to make the judgment i totally
understand that
and we have
we have let people down a few times
in medicine right
and i know two very
specific examples the first polio
vaccine ever made the salk vaccine was
released in 1955
immediately within months a few hundred
cases of paralysis and kids who got it
because it was not properly
inactivated
now you have to understand parents were
dying for a polio vaccine because kids
were getting paralyzed every summer 30
000 kids a year
and so they went and took it they took
the word of the medical establishment
that it was safe and it wasn't
big let down never going to forget
something although i think a lot of
people today don't don't aren't aware of
that
i think that was a big problem that's
everlasting then
um the
attenuated vaccine that we talked about
the infectious
causing polio yet parents continued to
bring their kids
to be vaccinated because they were said
this is the right thing to do and i have
to say i was involved in several
lawsuits where
parents of a kid who got paralyzed from
the polio vaccine decided to sue the
manufacturer
and get some some money for their for
their kid and so
they got mad
and and i think
you could not
the first
issue could have been prevented
could have been prevented by
inactivating it properly i think the
company just did the wrong thing
the second we had evidence for and we
should probably have not used that
vaccine any longer but i think that
destroys public confidence but those
aren't they're not long minority of
cases this minority this is a very rare
event yeah but nevertheless science is
an institution
uh didn't
make corrections in that case no they
didn't so what do you make of
that i mean it's very unfortunate that
those few things can destroy trust
but i don't think that lasts till today
i think today is a different era right
yeah and most people don't know about
those stories i tell them to you because
that's what could happen i think it
could happen today
if you look at the history of
the polio vaccine
the u.s public health service wanted
kids to be vaccinated
so they did things that probably weren't
correct to get the vaccine back online
right but they they did it and they
pushed it through
um so
the question is what do we do today
so
i can look at
as we just said i can look at what might
happen
and
i can
make reasonable
decisions about the likelihood of them
happening and i can also say
i don't want to get covet of any kind
because i've seen how nasty it can be
and i decide
i'm taking the risk whatever small of a
long-term effect i'm going to take the
risk my family took the risk and many
other people did of a vaccine of getting
vaccinated
because i think it's very small but i
understand where people can't make that
decision and that begs the question what
would they need
to make a decision so if you're
concerned about
an effect in 40
years we're not going to know for 40
years
you